plaisir tu cap est un peu non je dis ça
tombe mal on va faire l'interview je me
la pète
il se gausse où je me la pète
franchement tu te la fait la touche la
paix troqué dakar alors maintenant jean
paul rouve que votre talent est reconnu
est-ce que vous allez laisser tomber la
bande de guignols avec laquelle vous
traîner là depuis l'hérault bar là je
pense que là on va tourner d'autres
films ensemble et je pense qu'elle me
lasser ses derniers quoi c'est l'appât
ouais c'est un petit peu la fin j'ai un
peu de mal à maintenant de jouer avec
eux king pas au bout du chemin il assez
d'accord c'est vrai que vous refusez de
vous montrer avec marina parce qu'elle a
pas eu de césar oui parce qu'elle a
passé un cas là pas de sens à ces deux
raisons est-ce que leurs troupes l'aller
les robins c'est ça est ce que ça peut
survivre si vous y êtes plus bas non je
pense que c'est génial je le fais au
fait jean-paul compte tenu de votre
nouveau statut maintenant sa sauvegarde
de venir faire de la promo comme ça sur
les plateaux de télé ça va vous j'essaie
la dernière fois je construirai que je
viens chez vous par exemple un trop
populaire ouais je ferais bon prades
journal de 20 heures c'est tout
maintenant est bien sûr vous auriez
quels conseils à donner à un jeune
acteur qui déduit par exemple quand il
va en rire
moi je croyais ventes us et simplement
sois toi même tout simplement que essaye
d'être simple battant regarde les films
si tu as envie tout simplement tu y
arrives il paraît que hollywood reste de
vous là vous allez y aller non je sais
pas moi je vais voir franchis et quand
même à téléphoner lewis araki
l'américain les américains moi je dis
que si je peux tourner en français ah
oui et alors maintenant voulait coucher
avec qui mais vous êtes quand même césar
basques s'étaient plaints de février les
césar on est quand même au mois d'avril
j'ai crié j'ai fait il me reste que les
que léa par danielle darrieux je crois
que j'ai fait partie vous voulez quoi là
maintenant je voulais un truc on vous le
donne qu'est-ce qu'ils vont je crois que
j'ai un peu tout gégé le succès j'ai
physique je crois qu'on est tous des
jets j'entends rire là je sais pas en
quoi je crois que j'ai un peu tout j'ai
l'argent j'ai des voitures merci
beaucoup monsieur rouge c'était un
honneur pour moi